la course du soleil est le premier grand
rendez-vous de la saison cycliste
alors quand elle part des yvelines les
spectateurs ne loue pas l'occasion de
découvrir le peloton aux arts de paris
nice les coureurs voir un petit peu
l'envers du décor c'est impressionnant
non surtout avec les voitures et aux
donc semprun cela le passage d'une
grande course permet souvent de
découvrir le vélo sous toutes ses formes
mais le cyclisme c'est surtout un sport
chargé de braquet historique avec un
tour de france qui a fêté ses 100 ans en
les épopées des copies anti les autres
thévenet ont marqué les passionnés ou
plutôt les cadres sur lesquels ils
réalisaient leurs exploits le système du
vélo a pas trop changé par rapport à
observer un des cadres en carbone
déroule très légère les voyages on ne
roule plus avec des boyaux on roule avec
des pneus qui est plus facile et plus
facile pour la réparation
si les yvelines semble devenir la terre
promise du cyclisme avec le passage
régulier du tour de france ce cinquième
départ du paris nice et la naissance du
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
le monde de la a encore quelques
kilomètres à parcourir dans le cyclisme
est un sport qui manque de
reconnaissance qui n'est mis en devant
de la scène que
chaque année grâce au merveilleux
panorama quel tour de france on voit que
paris nice ça amène beaucoup de monde
c'est un événement vraiment majeur nous
effectivement notre objectif c'est de
faire venir les gens à la pratique du
cyclisme que ce soit de l'ue cyclisme
promenade du cyclisme compétition tout
est ouvert
ah oui pour la petite histoire l'espoir
français nacer bouhanni s'est imposé au
sprint après 162 km et a pris par la
même occasion le premier maillot jaune
de leader